Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
meinem Kanal.
In diesem Video zeige ich euch drei Möglichkeiten,
wie ihr aus Abfall, wie Zeitungspapier, oder
Eierkartons ganz einfach und schnell Pflanztöpfchen
für eure Gemüsepflanzen selber basteln könnt.
Gärtnern ist ja ein relativ ökologisches
Hobby, aber ich bin schon manchmal ganz schön
erstaunt, wie viel Plastikmüll da am Ende
doch trotzdem zusammen kommt.
Es fängt bei der Jungpflanzenanzucht an,
mit den ganzen Töpfchen, die man braucht.
Dagegen werden wir heute was unternehmen.
Dann geht es weiter mit irgendwelchen Mulchfolien,
mit dem ganzen Verpackungsmüll von den Sachen,
die man kaufen muss, um sie im Garten zu verwenden.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall immer relativ ambitioniert,
dass da möglichst wenig Plastikmüll bei
uns anfällt, ganz ohne kommen wir noch nicht
hin.
Vielleicht, wenn es jemand von euch schafft,
ganz ohne Plastik zu gärtnern, lasst mich
das mal gerne unten in den Kommentaren wissen.
Aber so selbstgebastelte Pflanztöpfchen,
sind auf jeden Fall schon mal ein guter erster
Schritt, nicht nur um Plastik zu sparen, sondern
auch um Geld zu sparen.
Weil die kosten nichts.
Fangen wir an mit den Klopapierrollen.
Die schneidest du einfach mal an vier sich
gegenüberliegenden Stellen jeweils zwei Zentimeter
tief ein.
Dann knickst du die ersten Laschen, die so
entstanden sind, in die Mitte.
Dann die zweite über die erste, die dritte
über die zweite, die vierte über die dritte
und gleichzeitig unter die erste, so dass
alles zusammenhält.
Dann noch einmal kurz flachdrücken, damit
das Pflanztöpfchen stehen kann und dann ist
es auch schon fertig.
Falls deine Pflanztöpfchen ständig umfallen,
das passiert manchmal, kannst du mit einem
Gummi aneinander fixieren, so wie ich das
hier gemacht habe und dann hast gar keine
Probleme mehr mit der Standfestigkeit, das
funktioniert dann sehr gut.
Dann einmal mit Anzuchterde füllen oder mit
Kompost.
Ich säe auch sehr gerne in reifem Kompost
aus, vor allem Starkzehrer.
Vielen Leute denken immer, dass das nicht
geht, aber ich habe damit sehr gute Erfahrungen
gemacht, solange der Kompost reif ist und
dann kannst du auch schon aussäen.
Ich habe hier zur Demonstration Erbsen gesät,
die ziehe ich normalerweise nicht im Haus
vor, aber weil die so schön schnell aufgehen,
habe ich das jetzt einfach mal gemacht.
Angießen und dann heißt es nur noch warten.
Für Variante Nummer zwei, brauchst du Zeitungspapier,
da habe ich einfach mal eine Seite genommen
und die in der Mitte gefaltet und jetzt schau
ich mit dem Glas, wie lang die Zeitungsseite
sein sollte.
Dieses Glas nehme ich als Hilfsmittel, um
das Pflanztöpfchen zu basteln und da schaue
ich jetzt, wie weit das unten übersteht und
dementsprechend muss man da unten dann was
abschneiden.
Die Zeitung sollte ungefähr vier Zentimeter
länger sein, als dein Glas hoch ist, so dass
du gleich alle Enden in die Mitte falten kannst
und das einen schönen Boden für dein Pflanzgefäß
ergibt.
Bei mir sind das jetzt hier so ungefähr acht
bis zehn Zentimeter, die ich abschneiden muss
und ich schneide die an der Seite ab, wo die
Seiten auseinander fleddern.
Also nicht an der Seite, wo der Knick ist.
Perfekt, jetzt kommt wieder das Glas ins Spiel
und ich wickele die Zeitung so um das Glas,
dass sie in zwei lagen um das Glas drum rumgewickelt
ist.
So ergibt das dann ein sehr stabiles Töpfchen,
dafür dass man einfach nur Zeitungspapier
verwendet hat, das ist ganz erstaunlich.
So der Rest wird abgeschnitten, dann stellt
man das Ganze auf den Kopf und knickt das
einmal unten um, so dass das einen Boden ergibt.
Und dann noch nicht abziehen vom Glas, jetzt
musst du nämlich einmal rund herum gehen,
und den Rand unten, diese äußere Kante so
ein bisschen zusammenknicken, weil das dann
den stabilen Boden ergibt.
So, dann kannst du das Töpfchen abziehen
und es ist fertig.
Einmal mit Erde füllen und dann kann natürlich
auch ein kleines Erbschen in das Töpfchen
einziehen.
Und für die dritte Möglichkeit, brauchst
du einen Eierkarton.
Da einfach mal den Deckel abschneiden, so
wie ich das hier mache.
Das ist wirklich die einfachste Methode, wie
man Pflanztöpfchen selber basteln kann, dafür
sind die relativ klein, das funktioniert also
nicht für alle Gemüse.
Einmal mit Kompost oder Anzuchterde füllen
und dann kannst du da direkt rein säen.
Noch schön angießen und fertig.
Ungefähr eine Woche bevor ich meine Pflänzchen
dann nach draußen pflanze, fange ich an die
draußen abzuhärten und sie langsam an Wind
und Wetter zu gewöhnen.
Bei den Klopapierrollen habt ihr zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ihr könnt entweder die Klopapierrolle einmal
außen um die Pflanze drum rum abschälen
und die Pflanze dann ohne Klopapierrolle direkt
in den Boden pflanzen.
Oder ihr reißt nur den Boden ab, dann könnt
ihr die Pflanze auch mit dem Rest der Klopapierrolle
pflanzen und die verrottet dann nach und nach.
Genauso funktioniert das mit den Töpfchen,
die man aus Zeitungspapier selber basteln
kann.
Ich bin immer eher der Typ, der die Sachen
abwickelt, weil ich nicht unbedingt Zeitungspapier
in meinen Beeten haben möchte.
Aber das würde auch ohne Probleme in deinem
Beet verrotten.
Die Pflänzchen, die in den Eierkartons gewachsen
sind, kann man auch sehr gut rausholen und
ohne Eierkarton pflanzen.
Dafür einfach einmal unten in den Boden kneifen,
dann kommt das Pflänzchen eigentlich ganz
gut von selber raus.
Ansonsten kannst du die auch ohne Probleme
mit dem Eierkarton pflanzen, der verrottet
auch so schnell, dass die Pflanzen sehr gut
ihre Wurzeln ausbreiten können und die Pappe
da nicht im Weg wäre.
Falls du noch mehr Tipps hast, wie man Pflanztöpfchen
selber basten kann, dann schreib das gerne
mal unten in die Kommentare.
Schau da auch gerne mal rein, ob da schon
andre Leute was Interessantes geschrieben
haben, ich finde das immer superspannend,
was da für ein Austausch herrscht.
Und es ist viel schöner, wenn wir uns da
gegenseitig weiterhelfen können, als wenn
ich hier die einzige bin, die zu euch redet.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du gerade dabei
bist, deine Jungpflanzen vorzuziehen, deswegen
glaube ich, dass dich dieses Video da oben
sehr interessieren könnte, da spreche ich
nämlich über die häufigsten Fehler bei
der Jungpflanzenanzucht.
Wenn du einen Pflanzplan brauchst, dann verlinke
ich dir meinen fertigen Plan gerne unten in
der Videobeschreibung, das ist ein fertig
ausgeklügelter Plan, den kannst du dir kostenlos
herunterladen und ausdrucken.
Da muss du dir nicht mehr den Kopf zerbrechen,
wie das denn genau funktioniert, mit der Anbauplanung,
Fruchtfolge, Mischkultur und was man da alles
beachten muss.
Aber ich habe noch mehr im Petto.
Hier rechts zeige ich dir nämlich, wie du
dein Saatgut organisierst und da unten findest
du auch noch ein spannendes Video.
Dann sehen wir uns hoffentlich gleich wieder,
bis dann.
Tschüs.
Der Pflanztöpfchen.
Hast du das gehört ja?
Konzentrier dich Marie.